let's jump to the story from Fox News
you know I'm 11 White House tells
Governors thousands of objects in the
skies aren't aliens could be used car
lot balloons the flying object's number
in the hundreds if not thousands and
could be anything from used car lot
balloons to aircraft launched by
commercial Enterprises a White House
official says well thanks for those
words of reassurance he says they're not
aliens this is not an invasion of aliens
I mean it's not it's funny but it's not
funny because people are communicating
this is on platforms that are widely
viewed and it's creating fear that is
unnecessary I segue into this story
because we've got a Chinese spy balloon
they shoot it down China is now
threatening retaliation we've now got
UFOs being shot down I'm wondering if
the United States is ready for some
comeuppance and I don't want to say
America and its ideals because I think
we were founded on on good things that
gradually got better and we got rid of
bad things but now we have a
military-industrial complex that is
hell-bent on invading other countries
for a variety of reasons destabilizing
the the North Africa and the Middle East
in in for cheap oil into our to our
allies countries
and China is ready to say we'll play
ball so I'm wondering if you think we're
headed towards some kind of actual
action either on Taiwan or on the US or
are we are we about to get into another
war in the Pacific Theater it seems like
world war three it seems like it they
they they can't stop Sable rattling and
these people are Reckless as hell I mean
it seems like it but let me just get
back to explaining what the petrol
dollar is so in 1970 whatever when Nixon
went off the gold standard we then
created the petrol dollar which he's
told Saudi Arabia
you can use our military wherever you
want us to use it you can use our
military which is why we're in Yemen
helping create a genocide now before
that uh so what what we get from Saudi
Arabia for the use of our military is
anybody who buys oil from Saudi Arabia
they're the number one exporter of oil
in the world anybody who buys it has to
buy it in U.S dollars so they have to
take whatever their currency is convert
it to US Dollars and then buy their oil
with the US Dollars and that what does
that do that artificially props up the
US dollar so that's why we're the
reserve currency around the world now
it's so as soon as that goes away which
it is going away because now Saudi
Arabia is starting to sell oil to China
in China's denomination and not US
Dollars also to India and they're all I
think Italy also uh so that will be the
end of the the the the Petro dollar
which will be the end of the US dollar
being the reserve currency around the
world which means our dollar will
collapse and along with our economy let
me add to that
the reason this props up the American
economy and makes Americans live so well
while having to do so little I'll give
you an example how is it that some
writer at buzzfeed's making 60 70 000 a
year serious question because the dollar
is artificially strong
in order for the dollar to be as strong
as it is normally we would have to mass
produce objects to sell we would have to
export things now to be fair we do
export culture people really want to
watch you know our celebrities and our
pop stars tour around the world then
this person plays a stadium in a foreign
country that sells millions of thousand
tickets they bring vote that money back
to this country and we can use it that's
a fair export Hollywood Etc movies
making a billion dollars overseas but we
do not export enough to keep the dollar
as strong as it is we just have lots of
guns and we tell people use it or else
the other thing we do is we give tax
dollars away and print money and give it
to other countries crossing our fingers
they will use it so it's a multi-faceted
economic system to prop up the Petro
dollar we do things like send 10 million
dollars to Pakistan for gender studies
did you hear about this no I didn't know
it was part of the big Omni muscle
Omnibus a couple years ago and
everyone's wondering why are we giving
10 million dollars to Pakistan for
gender studies it makes no sense it does
make sense if Pakistan has given 10
million dollars they say okay this is
great this is valuable and we'll use it
everyone around them then says we'll
sell you these eggs and they go all we
have is US Dollars and they go okay I
guess we'll take US Dollars it is
forcing confidence in this currency so
it's an economic incentive to give money
away to prop up our economy and then
there's a militaristic incentive of do
it or will I mean what happened to
Gaddafi yeah he was really interested in
in what gold in ours right yeah he was
going to create his own I think was
called the dinar that was going to be
the currency of Africa right and they
couldn't let that happen again and he
wanted to keep the oil for his people
whatever you want to do it's not good
same thing with we over we overthrew
Iran we overthrew Iraq we were through
Iran in the 50s Saddam Hussein I think
wanted to trade in Euro and use other
currencies and then you know and he gets
holed up quite literally and then hung
and so you can can't do that and so NATO
then invaded and bombed to Smithereens
to Libya turn it into a failed stay with
open slave markets decapitated their
leader and we just walked let's go and
then Barack Obama goes yeah that was a
mistake that was a mistake what did
Hillary Clinton say she she laughed she
said we came we saw he died did you see
her email with her emails about Sydney
Blumenthal with Osprey Global Solutions
one of Sydney's arms manufacturing
companies are he's basically a gun
Runner one of Bill Clinton's advisors
and he wasn't supposed to be involved
with the Obama Administration according
to Barack he said no I don't want Sydney
around but Sydney and Hillary are fast
friends they're old so he she basically
set up his company they had plans to set
up his companies two of his companies
one of his Osprey in Libya and then just
sell weapons to the new Administration
and it's all in her emails that came out
that should have exonerated Bernie
Sanders I don't know why Bernie was so
well let me ask you Jimmy I got you uh
what happens when the Petro dollar
collapses
I don't you know what I'm not smart
enough to know but it ain't good it is
not good twenty dollars I'm gonna guess
runaway inflation stuff like that and we
become worse than Brazil instant
hyperinflation for the obvious reason of
we Mass print money but we don't produce
things that's right where's our
manufacturing China China we're not
doing it so that means if we're not
producing things this was uh I can't
remember who had on the show they were
talking about this
um they said that oh this is Byron
Donald's he said you've got with the
coveted lockdowns no production so
Supply is low but they're giving money
to people so demand is high what does
that do it increases the cost of goods
high demand low Supply now what happens
when the US dollar collapses and we are
unable to buy things like laptops from
South Korea or you know Foxconn and
things like that or China stop selling
to us no Supply extremely high demand
and we are not producing anything to
trade so it's not just a supply issue
it's a we have nothing
then we're going to see you call it
hyperinflation I don't know what's
what's beyond hyperinflation well now
Currency Reset but that's if all of this
stuff is actually heading towards War if
if you know I'm worried about these
balloons I don't know what's going on
but China's threatening attacks on U.S
entities they're saying it it seems to
me that any move China is going to make
on Taiwan that's probably the first
thing they're going to do before any
kind of real war breaks out between us
and them it'll be they try to reclaim
Taiwan or I should say conquer Taiwan
because taiwan's the actual government
of China but then
I think we'll start to see things like
we're seeing now there will be sabotage
destabilization cyber attacks things to
disrupt the United States before they
make any hot conflict and lots of
confusion so in confusion if you look at
this article particularly these these
balloons now any for all we know these
balloons could be radar I don't know I
haven't seen any of I don't trust any of
it maybe that first balloon because
everyone took pictures of it but they've
got the stuff called talking plasma the
military works on this where they fire
lasers from base stations and
triangulate them in the sky with the
point that they all come together it
creates like a a blob of plasma that
they can move around really fast and
they'll be like how does a craft move
like that because it's freaking plasma
and they're going to tell you
they may be telling people that it's
something other than what it is so keep
your mind Project Blue beam yeah if you
can look it up that one I haven't heard
of that I don't think it's real to be
honest it's this conspiracy theory that
the government is going to use Advanced
holographic technology and you know
let's just say illusion technology it is
check up touch pull up now talking
plasma we can read about its military I
think it's the military times well right
right so so bluebeam is they're going to
try and create a fake image of God or
something to convince people of a new
religion using Holograms or something
like that okay I don't believe that
because that's an episode of Star Trek
that came out really four years before
the conspiracy theory but we are seeing
um creepy AI stuff we are seeing deep
fakes it's hard to know what's real and
as Ian's pointing out with talking
plasma where you're saying it's
triangulating lasers so it creates a
ball of light in the sky that moves
around in very strange ways it will look
like a vehicle it might be more than
triangle it might be like 100 lasers
coming together to create a really large
one it might be two lasers I think it's
three or more I'm not sure
if you have hundreds of these lasers you
can probably make it look like a vehicle
yeah yeah or an alien craft or some
crazy balloon and then it would move
instantly like light and people would
think it was a craft so the
psychological manipulations that we're
about to endure it's gonna be crazy I
mean the I don't know if you've seen the
AI deep fake stuff that's coming out I
doubted it when I was on Rogan last time
I don't doubt it anymore well what do
you mean you doubted it he Joe asked me
if I thought it was going to be really
bad and I was like no because like you
can already splice together fake videos
and convince people of things then I
started to see the degree and ladies you
can now I saw Elon Musk talking the
other day about how you he there's this
new AI computer that you can sound like
anybody look yeah you could use it on
the show oh so you know what I'm talking
about 11 Labs is the website and you
take a a 10 megabyte clip of someone
talking and you just click upload then
you type in what you want press enter
Boom the person says it that fast so
that's scary very scary yes there's
already a viral story we covered
yesterday where some company called uh
or the I don't say the company did it
but there's a company called Alpha grind
and it's a video from The Joe Rogan
podcast of Joe promoting this libido
booster that he claims will make you
bigger downstairs Joe I don't believe
ever talked about this they deep fake it
and run an ad because people probably
will fall for it and what do you do how
is first of all Joe has to find the ad
which is hard enough right maybe someone
tells him about it it's in the news now
so maybe Joe will hear about it but then
what send a cease and desist and they
say okay and they take down that one
video but remodel they've been
circulating five others right and what
happens when 10 000 people all do at the
same time right we assume how do you get
10 000 people to take it down take a
look at Wikipedia you they claim you
can't you can't sue Wikipedia because
it's user generated content it's but
it's not right and my argument is all
the Articles say from Wikipedia so
thereby lines on it but imagine this if
um NPC defames you you can sue NBC right
but here's what happens this happened to
me news Outlet writes fake news about me
instantly gets picked up by 10 other
outlets the original Source then
corrects it says whoopsie but all the
other outlets keep the lie yeah am I
gonna file 15 lawsuits I can afford that
so what happens if 10 000 people all
create a deep Faker View and upload it
who are you gonna Sue 10 000 people good
luck there's a good that's it I never
thought of any of this yeah so it's
gonna get real crazy it's the digital
wild west where people are like planting
their flags and there's no no oversight
people are just killing it
indiscriminately taking what they want
so think about a show like this right
now we've got 52 000 people watching if
they really yes
wow if every single person on a show
like this like I I want to be careful on
how I say this for obvious reasons but
I'll put it this way there are very
large shows that can get 10 to 20 to 50
000 live viewers and that person could
say something like oh won't someone rid
me of this priest and then even 10 make
a deep fake an embarrassing one and the
internet is flooded with these videos
that look real that sound real and you
can't do anything about it because even
if you hired a law firm to go after all
the fake videos there's no way to stop
them all and and
good luck it's not illegal it's just
what an infringement on your on your
life rights copyright infringement or
something these people will argue it's
parody we have videos of us check this
out there are videos of us from the show
they're really funny where someone will
splice together you know there's one
with me Phil and Alex Jones and it's
like us saying we love you each other or
something and it's an obvious joke
someone could make a deep fake of you or
anybody else saying something offensive
or embarrassing claim it's real and then
if it ever came to the point where they
were sued say it's satire good luck it's
gonna it's gonna be Bonkers in the next
month or two because I'm already seeing
this all over Instagram
the first thing I saw was Joe Rogan and
Jordan Peterson discussing the feminist
ethics of Super Mario Brothers and at
first I thought it was real because it
sounds like something they might talk
about but I'm like this is weird Joe
Rogan saying Princess Peach is a strong
character in her own right and Jordan
Peterson saying Mario's tracking without
consent and I'm like this is strange and
then I saw the comments and they're like
this is a this is a parody and I went
holy shh
that's that now imagine if everybody
starts doing it during an election cycle
too yup
so all this deep fake stuff is now at
the point where an individual can load
up 11 labs and in 10 seconds have an
audio clip of Joe Rogan endorsing Joe
Biden or Donald Trump and it will go
viral and people will put these things
out because if it tricks 10 people
they've succeeded if a hundred people
know well who cares because they've
succeeded in manipulating people and
getting those votes or or whatever so
don't but so though so now the scary
part is that this is going to lead them
to well we got to protect you from this
and so then they're going to censor and
then they're going to have an even
tighter control of what you can do and
say on the internet that's what I that's
the real downside of this is here's the
best part
there's going to be some video of maybe
Joe Biden or Trump doing something that
is believable but bad then people are
going to say yo that's a deep fake then
you're going to get a bunch of
politicians being like we've got to stop
this somehow then there will be a bunch
of deep fake videos of people being like
you know I honestly agree with censoring
this information and putting
restrictions in place to get to
manufacture consent from the public so
the Deep fakes will be the problem the
Deep fakes will convince people of the
solution and then they'll implement it
instead of censoring I think we should
maybe force the software code open I
don't know if that's even possible in
this circumstance but if you could force
transparency on the system that would be
way better than trying to blank it out I
will say this I think the first thing
that will happen is Twitter YouTube
Facebook Etc will need to implement deep
fake scanning technology
so then they will flag them so I think
what they do on on Twitter is parity
accounts have to say parity and you you
get the bird watching that says this is
a parity account to warn people
but I think with the Advent of deep fake
technology it's scary now but what we
really need is for a company to create a
filter that will tell you if something's
a deep fake or not then Twitter needs to
implement it so in that video of Donald
Trump saying something offensive appears
there will be a big exclamation point
saying this video was generated by
Deepak and if the filter is open source
then you'll know that it's a legitimate
scan but what if like I just know
nothing about technology but if I see a
video that's a deep fake but I don't
know it and I screen record it therefore
generating a new video since I posted on
my Twitter saying is this real is that
going to get picked up in these kinds of
uh scanners like are is since it's a new
type of content like I've technically
made a new video would they be able to
tell that it's D fake I mean because how
do you take stuff off the internet right
I know we talked the story to death but
the the girls on I think it was twitch
who were upset because they realized
that there are there's AI generated porn
of them
what am I gonna have you heard this
story oh there was a streamer who got
caught I guess looking looking at a
company that you can you know request a
public figure space you can upload their
image of a person's face and they'll put
it on a woman getting banged yeah so it
makes porn and so there are you know in
particular a couple different streamers
who were saying you know I I have to
fight this legally I didn't make this
it's my image being used against my will
how am I supposed to stop this and at
that point anyone who's watched it who's
recorded it now has that has it and can
put it up anywhere I mean how do you put
this back in the box it's really
difficult here's the crazier thing too
let's say Joe Biden gets caught on a hot
mic saying something really offensive
they could say it's a deep exactly oh
that was a deep fake you never said that
and also like if I'm gonna take your
likeness Jimmy for instance if I made a
deep pic of you but with a large
forehead is that impersonation no what
if it's just a little bit bigger yeah if
people if you can do an impersonation of
someone that sounds uh you know it's
uncanny nobody bats an eye you're
allowed to do it so what's the
difference between if you did that or
used a an AI voice generator for for
parity purposes how could you sue you
know it's like Sheamus does Jordan
Peterson's voice all the time
it's not like a one for one it's obvious
that it's an impersonation but as Jordan
Peterson gonna Sue and be like hey
that's my voice you can't use it no but
what if you used an AI to make it for
the same exact reason what's the
difference a tool to impersonate versus
physically doing it yeah there's that's
interesting territory man I would say
that there's got to be some way to
discern that that it's not an
impersonation that it's slightly off but
good luck because the Tech's so good
they're just gonna make it exact it
reminds me of copyright law with music
right when you have notes and they'll
say this is just this is just enough
altered so it doesn't infringe on this I
mean it will become very difficult
especially if you're saying oh well it's
Sheamus's voice but he's endorsing a
product and it's making it sound like
the watching the courts sort this out is
going to be fascinating but it means
that a lot of people will uh be ruled
against right their images will be
allowed to be manipulated
like they say the law is decided in the
courts I'm finding more and more that
laws decided in technology code I think
it's decided by the judges most of the
time is decided by human culture because
a judge will not rule in a way that
would get a Molotov thrown through his
window the the law can say no putting a
pie on your windowsill on Sunday and no
cops going to arrest someone because it
makes no sense multi cocktail or uh
prevent him from being appointed to a
position he may want to be or prevent
him from buying a muffin at his local
bakery I don't know but it's going to do
whatever they think if everybody thinks
that dogs are illegal but the technology
is telling you that there are no dogs
that No One's Gonna the culture's almost
irrelevant we may be getting to that
point where we rely on Google and search
and soon AI for our information because
if you go to Google and you ask you type
in you know did X happen and it says it
never happened because all these news
articles pop up people believe that and
that becomes their reality let me let me
pull in this Vlog here and they do
control uh what you see
so that Google does like their algorithm
you don't know like uh that was what the
big thing with Dogpile remember they
were like uh that's another search
engine and everybody got bummed out when
they said hey we're gonna go along with
the coveted narrative we're working oh
doc dot go oh duck yeah Duck Duck Duck
Go yep they were like we're gonna start
censoring information we're gonna start
de-ranking that and we're going to start
like boosting authoritative sources
you're like this is not what you guys
don't that's what Google does you don't
have to do that so of course big Pharma
got some money in there somehow that's
all that was thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time